hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
in the next half hour then we'll see
what's making the headlines with tonight
the chief leader writer at the observer
sonia soder and the former conservative
special adviser anita boten welcome and
great to see both of you
as ever though we turn our attention
first of all to the front pages
10 days in a hotel room or it's 10 years
in a cell if you lie
that is the uk government's tough new
quarantine rule for
international arrivals and that is the
lead for the metro
the move has been criticized by tory mps
and travel industry bosses
according to the telegraph
the tightening of the rules for those
arriving from so-called redless
countries also makes the front page of
the financial times
travelers will have to pay 1 750 pounds
for their stay
in quarantine facilities according to
the yorkshire post
that is also the main story for the
guardian coveted travel rule breakers
facing
a risk of 10 years in jail the sun has
an exclusive about the effectiveness of
curvit-19 vaccines
just one dose offers two-thirds
protection against the virus according
to data from the rollout everyone is a
winner they say
while the eye reports that new covet
variants are
under control delhi express describes
the reintroduction
of parking charges for nhs staff as a
kick in the teeth despite their work
during the pandemic daily mirror reports
there's an outcry as some of the permits
could cost staff up to 500 pounds a year
and the daily star offers readers the
chance to imagine piers morgan
do we have to as prime minister
well anyway yes fascinating uh so
sony soda and anita botang are here with
rather more serious matters
not least 10 years in prison if you look
at the metro anita
goodness me i i imagine there was a
sharp intake of breath in the
in the house of commons today absolutely
and it's very interesting that matt
hancock kind of prefaced it by saying
i make absolutely no apologies for the
toughness of this measure
and i think that really speaks to the
intention here and it's not to lock
people up for 10 years
but to act as a very serious deterrent
and encourage real compliance and
honesty
about people that have been in these red
flag countries
over the past 10 days yeah and the
difficulty is that other nations like
south korea for example
they track your credit card or debit
card details
they basically we would argue impinge
our
our privacy in order to track us we're
still not doing that are we so
do you think this might work sonia and
is it the right thing to do
i mean i think it's it's certainly quite
the deterrent isn't it the idea of five
years or even 10 years in prison
i'm a bit cynical about this i think the
government really wanted
a headline to sort of grab people's
attention
and maybe shift the debate away from
whether these measures go
far enough it's been a big debate about
that in the last few years
it will last you days rather it does
feel like yes doesn't it um you know is
it enough to just say that
people coming in from the 35 redless
countries
have to quarantine in a hotel or should
it be everyone and by sort of announcing
this prison
potential prison sentence the government
has really shifted the headlines onto
that aspect of the debate i mean it does
feel like
a massive massive deterrent um
i think it does raise questions though
because you know that there are a number
of questions that have been raised today
about how this is going to work on a
practical level so for example if you've
got people coming in from a red less
country
there's no way of knowing exactly who
they are as they come through the
airport so the government is really
relying on people being
honest and self-declaring and seventeen
hundred and fifty pounds which is the
charge that you've got to pay
to quarantine in a hotel for ten days
and to take the tests on day two
and day eight that the government are
now going to be requiring you to take
you know that's that's a huge chunk of
the charge so i think the government has
probably looked at this and thought
we just simply don't have the capacity
or the wherewithal perhaps to track
people coming in from what country
they're coming in we've got to rely on
honesty
and actually given the charge is so high
we're going to have to really scare
people into doing this so i think this
is kind of where it's coming from
yes indeed and we are reminded are we
not that it is illegal to travel outside
the uk right now
unless there are exceptional
circumstances so you know if
those are exceptional circumstances and
you're willing to pay that 1750 pounds
then so be it
scotland's reacted differently hasn't it
anita decided that all travellers need
to
hotel quarantine and do you think this
stiff penalty
is a way of getting around that
criticism that the 33
red list countries don't go far enough
because clearly people can get
joining flights can't they well
i think the purpose of this is really
that point to reinforce and underline
the fact that people
should not be traveling unless
absolutely necessary
and and that is really the key here
we're not saying every family that
fancy's going over to greece is going to
have to do this
the purpose is to discourage um this
kind of travels so i think it is
proportionate when you factor that
in and just to pick up on this point
that sonia made about
um you know the government really just
relying on people to do the right thing
i think that's been the government's
approach to this entire pandemic it
requires everyone
to be responsible to take personal
accountability
and to really act within the letter and
the spirit of the rules and i think
we're seeing that continued here
with a bit of underlining to reinforce
the point that there will be enforcement
action
if you don't comply yes and the daily
telegraphs on you really kind of brings
it home doesn't it
ten years in jail for holidaymakers who
lie about going to portugal that just
feels a bit near
i mean it does doesn't it i think what's
interesting
is actually the criticism has come from
all wings of the conservative party
so you've got people who would be
traditionally be seen as being on the
right of the party criticizing this but
you've also got dominic you know a
lawyer like dominic grieve
um criticizing this he's sort of
considered to be more on the kind of
left of the party
and i think there is a concern about
introducing penalties as grave and as
serious as this through secondary
legislation
you know it's not being scrutinized by
parliament
in the way that you would expect for uh
something like this i think so i think
that's where the concern comes from
but i i do think that we shouldn't let
the debate about the penalty
distract us from the real question which
is you know what is the point
of this policy the government says it's
about reducing
uh the risk of new variants like the
south african variants
that you know may prove to be more
resistant to vaccines from coming into
this country
now if you're only going to prevent
travel if you're only going to say that
people have to quarantine in hotels
coming in from you know quite a discreet
number of countries and you're waiting
for countries to sort of
find these new variants track them lots
of countries don't have the level of
genomic testing that we do
that enables you to find a new variant
quickly
um you know it does kind of beg the
question because
you do sort of feel that probably by the
time that we've discovered
a new variant and the government's taken
action it will be too late and it would
have already come into the uk so i think
that's why some people are asking the
question
if you look at countries that have been
really successful
at not getting kind of new strains and
you know
covert spreading through people coming
in through international travel
they've taken a more blanket approach
than just looking at say you know 33
discreet countries and as
john ashworth the shadow health
secretary raised in the commons today
not every country that has got known
cases of the south african variant is on
that list and
he was asking why and i think it is a
good question
yes indeed and we have as we're reminded
again all this genomic
sequencing so we find these variants not
necessarily to the benefit of the uk
because obviously nobody wants us as
travelers
right now do they because of the kent
variant are you confident do you think
that
this argument oh the horse has already
bolted can be solved by the surge
testing which is already underway anita
both tonight we heard in south london
and then
in bristol and manchester where the kent
variant has developed the mutations of
the south african variant so a
kind of double whammy there um do you
think the surge testing can keep it keep
it in check is that the
the hope of government i think
there's no silver bullet so it's got to
be the surge testing
alongside the vaccination because
ultimately coronaviruses do not mutate
very easily
and one of the reasons why they are
mutating so much is because there's just
so many cases around so if the
government can combine this surge
testing
with the vaccination i think that really
will make a considerable difference
and just to respond to this point about
new strains
the key point that matt hancock
announced today was specifically
that actually they're going to introduce
genomic testing
for those passengers are coming into the
country on day two
so we will be able to identify new
strains and that genomic testing will
apply to anyone that tests positive
coming from whatever country so the
government will be able to identify
other countries that have new variants
or should be
on the list of 33 so i think this is
going to deliver
a real step change in the government's
response yes global
uh cooperation because presumably
they'll pass that information back to
those nations weren't they
um onto the guardian just quickly then
sonia similar sort of
front page there but they've started
talking about people who could bypass
the scottish rules i mean you've got
layers of complexity
of bypassing this haven't you because
clearly scotland's gone further and
suggested that all passengers need to go
into hotel quarantine
yes so um scotland says it doesn't
matter where you're coming in from if
you're coming into scotland
unless there are kind of real
extenuating kind of circumstances
you have to do your 10 days of
quarantine in a hotel
and what it raises questions in a
devolved nation like ours where
scotland's going down
one approach england wales and northern
ireland are doing something different
is that obviously raises concern so the
scottish government is saying
if you're coming to scotland via england
then you
it doesn't matter what country you're
coming from you have to do your 10 days
of quarantine in a hotel
but there are real questions about how
you would enforce that
um you know there's obviously it's very
expensive the 1750 pounds so
um you know people might have an
incentive to sort of fly in through
england and then cross you know drive up
to scotland or get the train up to
scotland
so i think it just you're right it's a
very very complex issue
and it raises all sorts of questions
we're an island nation but when
different bits of the island
go down different paths when it comes to
international travel that does raise
questions about
how you coordinate and how you make sure
that a different policy
applies for scotland consistently in a
way that means that people
you know can't get around it and
elsewhere in pandemic news
a couple of the newspapers anita talking
about 500 pound
parking charges for nhs staff um
tell us about this one is it one trust
in particular
yes it is and i think you know hospital
parking charges have been a big
political bugbear for the government for
a very long time i'm sure some of your
viewers will remember
rory stewart during the 2019 leadership
election pledging to make them free
and the government has provided a lot of
investment to do so
but it does seem like one of the trusts
hasn't been able to to deliver on that
and so
i think this is absolutely the wrong
time um for them to be going through
those struggles and i really hope that
they
managed to find a way to to really
alleviate the pressure
um i do think this is going to be a
continued debate you know how much
can we compensate and reward the amazing
doctors and
and nurses that worked incredibly hard
and obviously care home workers
do this entire pandemic and is that
going to be you know pay rises
anything like that i think that will be
a continued debate in the coming months
yes and even this is epsom and helia nhs
trust which has blamed rising demand
uh and the mirror with a quote here from
work is saying but we've had staff die
so i think uh you know as you say these
issues will be
part of the debate in the months and
weeks ahead well plenty was still to
come
including the start of the former
president donald trump's second
impeachment trial that and more after
this
[Music]
i'm siobhan robins sky southeast asia
correspondent
in bangkok we take you to the heart of
the stories
that shape our world i'm so proud of her
she
first locked down and when she said that
she wanted to
raise some money to help some charities
that are really close to our heart i was
so proud
and she raised an incredible amount of
money um
and it wasn't easy for her she's you
know she got on the treadmill most days
and
and powered away on there and this time
she's a little bit stronger
and she's been working hard with a
physio and
she said that she wanted to do it again
and then we said
um you know it might be a little bit
more difficult this time with a
full day of homeschooling as well um but
she was determined that she was going to
do another marathon so
hats off to where she you know she's um
she's really good my left leg
when i walk about 300 meters my left leg
really starts to hurt
and i have to stop and then i walk again
and then i stop so it takes a bit longer
to um walk around
but i do it anywhere because yeah it's
really time consuming for her but
she's determined to do it
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
the people here are praying quietly to
themselves
they're becoming very sensitive about
having the media around
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
there's a lot of action going on
[Music]
every time they touch them they spray
sprayed spray
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
for the early
headline for risers knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
the safety ridge what's that they
podcast for the ones who want to know
more welcome to the all-out politics
podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free well welcome back you're
watching the press preview with me now
chief leader writer for the observer
sonia soder and the former conservative
special adviser anita botan welcome back
to both of you
um so impeachment of the former u.s
president
um does he already feel like yesterday's
man should shouldn't be going ahead
they've been debating that today haven't
they
sonia but it's uh the top picture story
there for the financial times
that's right and today really the first
day of the trial was all about whether
it's constitutional to try him
um for these crimes or not because he's
no longer in office
um i think it's just happened off the
press
uh the senate has voted to proceed with
the trial
but i think neither the democrats nor
the republicans really want it to drag
on for too long
we've got president biden in office now
um
you know he's got a huge amount to be
getting on with with coved
obviously there's a clear point of
principle here
which is that you know trump did incite
uh
you know an insurrection um in the
capital and so there's a point of
principle about the trial proceeding
but most commentators think it's quite
unlikely that the senate will
convict him because um it requires a
two-thirds majority
in the senate that obviously spit very
nearly 50-50 with kamala harris with the
casting vote
so it's very unlikely that the democrats
will get the 67 votes in the senate they
need
to convict him so i think it will be
about you know
going through the motions hearing some
of these arguments but most people think
it isn't going to last
the three weeks that trump's last
impeachment trial lasted
yes and that basic charge obviously of
uh incitement is um
refuted by his supporters and many
republicans too so we'll see what
happens in the
in the coming days full coverage of that
tomorrow but let's move on to anita the
guardian shall we
um which is this cladding safety crisis
post grenfell which has left
many homeowners and uh and leaseholders
in in a really difficult situation
hasn't it
yeah and it's been particularly tough
even for first-time
buyers a lot of people that we consider
themselves conservative voters and the
spectators done a lot of campaigning
about this too
and so essentially these are homeowners
who have bought flats but have found
that they actually have this
planning that's very expensive to
replace and they cannot sell it either
so it seems as though robert generic has
been negotiating hard behind the scenes
with rishi soon after chancellor
and they've agreed a package of
financial support to help these
homeowners and i don't think it
can come soon enough
you